Trascrizione: Federico Sangati
Revisore: Ariana Bleau Lugo
Buonasera a tutti!
È un onore è una gioia immensa
essere qui con voi.
Mamma mia che teatro meraviglioso!
Mi hanno suggerito di incominciare
con una breve presentazione mia
e dei temi che andrò a trattare,
allora ho pensato di cominciare
con questa immagine
che mostra tutta la mia
balda prestanza atletica fin da bambino.
Tranquilli, non mostrerò
tutte le foto dell'album dell'infanzia!
Però volevo partire da qui
perché mi sono reso conto
che questi sono stati anni importanti
tra i più formativi di tutta la mia vita
durante i quali ho imparato
alcune cose fondamentali.
Ho imparato l'amore per la natura,
ho imparato il valore dell'amicizia,
ho imparato il piacere del gioco
e il dispiacere degli sbuccioni
nelle ginocchia
come credo tanti di noi da bambini.
Non meno importanti sono stati
gli anni a venire
durante i quali ho scelto
di impegnarmi come volontario
con l'associazione Mani Tese.
Sono stato 20 volte in Africa a seguire
dei progetti di solidarietà.
Abbiamo fatto tantissimi progetti,
pozzi, scuole, ospedali.
Abbiamo cancellato da intere aree
soprattutto in Burkina Faso ma non solo,
la fame, la sete, l'analfabetismo.
Abbiamo fatto progetti per promuove
i diritti dei bambini e delle donne.
È stata una gioia,
una sensazione meravigliosa.
Ho imparato tanto, ho cambiato
il mio modo di vedere il mondo,
ho capito che le cose possono cambiare.
In Africa ho compreso i valori
della solidarietà, della giustizia,
della pace, dell'intercultura
e ho maturato questa empatia
verso i nostri fratelli vicini e lontani
che sono i valori che cerco
di promuovere nella mia attività
educativa e culturale
soprattutto con i ragazzi ma non solo.
È un impegno educativo
che cerco di portare avanti
un po' come un gioco.
Io credo avesse ragione
George Bernard Shaw quando diceva
che noi non smettiamo di giocare
perché invecchiamo,
ma invecchiamo
perché smettiamo di giocare.
Se questo è vero
abbiamo l'elisio dell'eterna giovinezza.
E io penso sia vero
perché mi è capitato
nel corso della mia vita
di incontrare dei giovani
già alle scuole medie vecchi e tristi
e invece degli anziani giovani.
Ricorda una volta
stavo per partire per l'Africa
e pochi giorni prima ero
all'ufficio vaccinazioni internazionali
ho incrociato lungo il corridoio
una giovincella 96enne
che usciva mentre io stavo entrando,
è stata bellissima la scena
che voglio condividere con voi,
l'infermiere è uscita dalla porta
e le è corsa dietro per dire
un qualcosa che avevo dimenticato.
È la procedura.
L'infermiera visibilmente imbarazzata
le ha detto:
"Vede signora,
tra 10 anni ci sarebbe il richiamo."
E la signora si è voltata e ha detto:
"E se mi dimentico?"
E l'infermiera ha detto:
"Non si preoccupi,
glielo ricorderemo noi."
Io ero lì che assistevo,
non la conoscevo, ho detto:
"Voglio invecchiare così, come lei!"
Allora se è il gioco
che ci può mantenere giovani,
vi chiederò oggi di giocare con me.
Proprio come fanno i bambini.
Io cerco di vivere in questo modo.
Quali sono i temi?
Dimenticavo, i temi
che vorrei trattare con voi oggi.
Sono tre fondamentalmente:
1. Come impariamo.
Quindi processi di apprendimento
qualche spunto di riflessione,
con umiltà.
2. Come possiamo cambiare
il nostro modo di pensare
e le nostre abitudini.
3. E come possiamo educare e educarci
alla felicità.
Penso che sia questo in fin dei conti
il primo obbiettivo della nostra vita.
Iniziamo con un gioco,
vi richiederei di alzarvi subito.
Volete giocare con me?
Scusate prima non ve l'ho chiesto.
Vi chiederei di alzarvi in piedi.
Sì, sì, tutti!
È un gioco semplicissimo
e forse qualcuno di voi
l'avrà già fatto.
Vi chiedo molto semplicemente,
tenete pure giù le braccia,
appoggiate qualunque cosa abbiate,
di incrociare le braccia.
Guardate ora come le avete incrociate.
Scommetto che di solito
le incrociate sempre così, no?
Guardate attentamente qual è la mano
che sta sopra e quella che sta sotto.
Ora liberatele.
Ora proviamo a incrociarle al contrario.
Come andiamo?
Ce l'avete fatta tutti?
3 semplicissime considerazioni
su questo piccolo esercizio.
Primo: cambiare è possibile.
(Risate)
Secondo: richiedi un po' d'impegno
perché va contro le nostre abitudini
che ci fanno arrugginire
e ci irrigidiscono.
Terzo: può anche essere divertente.
Potete tornare a sedere.
(Applausi)
Mi hanno detto "Chi cerca trova",
però chi di noi,
almeno una volta nella vita,
non ha perso qualcosa in casa
ora dite la verità.
Cioè è una sensazione sgradevole!
La cerchiamo ovunque,
ce l'abbiamo magari sotto al naso
ma non riusciamo a ritrovarla.
Più ci ostiniamo e peggio è.
Se invece la lasciamo perdere
per un attimo, facciamo altro,
ritorniamo, ed ecco dov'era,
era lì sul tavolo!
La stessa cosa accade
quando non riusciamo
a richiamare alla memoria una parola,
avete presente la sensazione
di averla sulla punta della lingua.
Oppure per un musicista quando
ci incantiamo
che sia pianoforte o chitarra
non importa, qualunque strumento,
ci incantiamo
su una sequenza di note sbagliate
e ci intestardiamo nel tentativo
sforzandosi di richiamare alla memoria
ciò che avevamo perduto facendo peggio.
Ci sono ricerche scientifiche
su questo che dimostrano
come assolutamente i tentativi ripetuti
di richiamare alla memoria un qualcosa
siano controproducenti.
È come se, paradossalmente,
gli errori che facciamo in questa ricerca
quando vengono ripetuti tante volte,
anche se poi vengono corretti,
ci portassero, paradossalmente,
proprio all'apprendimento dell'errore.
E penso anche alla famosa frase
che ci hanno detto 100 volte da bambini
"sbagliando si impara".
Ecco, io la penso un po' come
Charlie Brown a riguardo.
(Nella vignetta Charlie Brown dice:
Mi sembra che ci sia qualcun altro
che sta imparando
dai miei errori al posto mio)
(Applausi)
Se fosse vero
che sbagliando s'impara,
noi dovremmo essere tutti perfetti,
come individui e come società.
Invece continuiamo, pensateci,
paradossalmente a ripetere
sempre gli stessi sbagli.
Per esempio facciamo le stesse litigate
come il giorno prima,
come società ripetiamo
sempre gli stessi errori.
Io credo che allora non sia bene.
Cioè fondamentalmente
noi impariamo in un altro modo:
noi impariamo dai nostri successi.
Voglio farvi soltanto un esempio
che è un'intuizione da cui è partito
un mio percorso di ricerca
su questo tema,
che veniva dall'osservazione,
da 20 anni di esperienza educativa
coi ragazzi
e anche l'esperienza
di impegno sociale.
Io comunque ho notato
che l'apprendimento deriva
fondamentalmente dai nostri successi.
Vi faccio un esempio, perché
lo abbiamo condiviso tutti da bambini.
Quando abbiamo imparato
ad andare in bici senza le rotelline.
Ve lo ricordate?
Io ricordo il giorno
in cui il mio babbo disse:
"Michele, ormai sei grandicello
puoi anche togliere le rotelline,
proviamo!"
"Babbo, non sta sù.
Ci ho provato, ci ho provato!
Tra l'altro quello
è un momento drammatico
perché uno si guarda intorno
e vede che tutti sanno andare in bici.
Per l'autostima è una botta terrible!
Sono l'unico pirla dell'universo
che non riesce
ad imparare ad andare in bici.
Ma quand'è che noi possiamo dire di avere
davvero imparato ad andare in bici?
Certo saremo caduti 50 volte
e ci siamo dovuti rialzare.
Ma il momento in cui possiamo dire
davvero di avere imparato
è quando per la prima volta
magari in modo fortuito
e un po' traballante,
siamo riusciti a rimanere in equilibrio.
Perché è quel movimento
che noi abbiamo memorizzato
e imparato poi a replicare.
Certo, occorreva cadere e rialzarsi.
Non c'è un'altra via
che porti al successo se non questa.
Un proverbio giapponese Zen recita così:
il successo nella vita
è cadere 9 volte e rialzarsi 10.
Quindi non dobbiamo
avere paura di sbagliare
ce l'hanno detto anche questa mattina
questo non ci deve frenare o paralizzare,
ma nella consapevolezza
che poi sono i successi
che ci portano
ad un apprendimento rinforzato,
ma anche su questo
non voglio tediarvi.
Ci sono infinite ricette
sia etologiche, sugli animali,
sia fisiologiche ché neurofisiologiche
che dimostrano come
la memoria di apprendimento
per un successo è 7 volte più duratura
nel nostro cervello rispetto alla
memoria di un insuccesso.
L'idea che dobbiamo per forza bruciarci
la mano per imparare non è fondata.
Ecco questo è fondamentale,
l'altro aspetto che volevo dire
è che noi non impariamo
solo dai nostri successi,
ma anche dai successi altrui.
E questo è un passaggio
evolutivo decisivo.
Se capiamo che noi possiamo imparare
dai successi altrui,
questo accelera enormemente
il nostro processo di apprendimento.
Se ci pensiamo un attimo
ci accorgiamo che è sempre stato così.
Non è niente di nuovo,
quello che io vi propongo
e ciò che è sempre accaduto
nel corso della storia.
Noi siamo in realtà il frutto
di un'eredità culturale di popoli
che per centinaia di anni,
per secoli, millenni,
si sono scambiati
tutto ciò che si poteva scambiare.
Idee, scoperte, invenzioni, cibi, arte,
musica, danza, spettacolo, scienza
mogli, tutto quello
che ci si poteva scambiare.
(Risate)
(Grazie)
Da tutti i punti di vista, scherzando
coi ragazzi faccio una scommessa e dico:
scommetto che parlate meglio
l'arabo che l'inglese.
Ovviamente parliamo benissimo l'arabo.
Usiamo nella nostra lingua italiana
centinaia di parole mutuate
da altre lingue,
dall'arabo, al gotico, longobardo,
franco, aramaico.
Lo stesso vale per i giochi:
fin da bambini abbiamo giocato
con le trottole egizie,
lo yoyo delle Filippine,
l'aquilone cinese, la dama egizia,
gli scacchi persiani.
Tutta la nostra cucina,
l'abbigliamento, tutto.
Noi siamo il frutto di questo scambio
interculturale che ci ha arricchito
per secoli e millenni
portandoci dove siamo ora.
Io ci tengo a dire una cosa.
Che dall'antichità,
dalla ruota dei Sumeri,
al timone dei Fenici,
alla bussola dei cinesi,
fino alla birra
che i Sumeri producevano
4000 anni prima dei tedeschi,
o alla cioccolata in tazza,
che gli Aztechi producevano
1200 anni prima degli svizzeri.
Questo siamo noi.
Io l'ho riassunto con questa espressione:
1 + 1 = 3
Ed è magia, capite bene
che non funziona così
coi soldi, sarebbe bello ma no,
o con gli oggetti.
La cultura è l'unica cosa
che davvero cresce
globalmente quando ce la scambiamo.
Faccio un esempio
per non essere lungo,
perché il format TED mi sta
come una camicia 7 taglie più piccole.
15 minuti sono faticosi per me!
Pensate soltanto,
ecco ho dimenticato una slide
ve la faccio vedere.
Ecco mi ha fatto perdere il filo...
Potete anche applaudire, non è vietato.
(Applausi)
Parlerò di talenti e limiti,
uno dei miei limiti è la poco memoria,
portate pazienza.
Una cosa che secondo me è molto
importante è questa cosa qua.
Uno più uno uguale a tre.
Vi faccio solo un esempio
per non dilungarmi.
Pensate a quando Gutenberg
inventa la stampa a caratteri mobili.
Sapete come è nata?
Lui unisce due idee
molto lontane fra loro,
cioè gli stampi per il conio delle monete
e la pressa per l'uva per farvi il vino.
E nasce la stampa a caratteri mobili.
Ora abbiamo smesso di battere moneta?
Non mi pare.
Abbiamo smesso di produrre il vino?
Dio ce ne scampi!
Ma abbiamo anche
la stampa a caratteri mobili.
Uno più uno uguale a tre.
La sintesi combinatoria
è alla base del processo creativo
che ha portato a tutte le invenzioni
della storia umana dalla clava all'Ipad.
Questa è la base del processo creativo!
E su questo noi dovremo,
secondo me, lavorare.
Faccio una piccola distinzione
perché troppo importante
dal punto di vista lessicale.
Ho utilizzato fino ad ora
in maniera abbastanza intercambiabile
il termine sbagliare e errare.
Non ho fatto bene.
Perché in realtà
hanno due etimologie molto diverse.
Sbagliare deriva dal latino
varius, cangiante, abbagliante
che ci distrae,
sbagliano quando siamo distratti,
quando non siamo presenti.
Invece errare, come ci diceva
questa mattina l'amico in prima fila,
errare significa letteralmente
andare senza una meta, vagabondare,
e questo sì che invece può essere
molto fruttuoso
per portarci a scoprire tantissime cose
che non avevamo neanche previsto,
che non stavamo cercando.
È quello che viene normalmente
chiamato serendipity,
richiamato anche
nel bellissimo intervento
in apertura di questo TED.
Cosa significa?
Riuscire a cogliere ciò che casualmente
ci capita lungo il cammino
essendo presenti appunto,
e da qui sono nate alcune delle cose
più strabilianti nel corso della storia.
Ci hanno ricordato questa mattina
la famosa mela caduto in testa a Newton
che gli ispirò
la legge di gravità universale.
Ma pensate ad Archimede, quando lui uscì
fuori dalla vasca da bagno urlando Eureka!
Dalla penicillina al pap test,
dall'insulina all'anestesia,
passando attraverso
la gravitazione universale
piuttosto che la corrente elettrica,
mi vengono in mente anche scoperte
molto materiali come il nylon,
la pentola antiaderente,
il velcro, il post-it,
tutte queste cose sono il frutto
di serendipity,
cioè di scoperte fatte da persone
che non stavano cercando quello
o che non stavano cercando affatto,
ma che erano presenti nel momento.
Lo sbaglio sarebbe stato
essere distratti,
quindi non riuscire a cogliere
ciò che lungo il cammino
ci offriva una possibilità
di intuizione
così come è stato detto anche prima.
Un'altra precisazione che vorrei fare:
molte di queste scoperte
sono state fatte da persone
che nella vita si occupavano
di tutt'altro.
Siamo abituati a pensare
che ci siano i professionisti
e gli specialisti sono loro,
che cercano e trovano.
Salvo poi scoprire
che ad esempio
la pellicola codacon fu inventata
da un musicista,
il parchimetro da un giornalista,
il telefono automatico
da un impresario di pompe funebri,
la penna a sfera da uno scultore
e potrei continuare, quindi capite
non c'è qualcuno a cui possiamo delegare.
Mi è piaciuto quando prima
De Angelis ha detto:
"Io ho già fatto due imprese,
adesso fatene una anche voi!"
Siamo tutti indispensabili,
questo mi sembra era fondamentale.
Allora dobbiamo ripartire
mettendo al centro le relazioni,
il miracolo delle relazioni, la poesia,
la meraviglia che c'è
nelle relazioni umane.
Quindi dobbiamo, secondo me,
liberarci dalle catene di un consumismo
che ci ruba anzitutto il tempo per
gli affetti, per gli hobby, per i sogni,
e invece riappropriarci del piacere
della meraviglia che c'è nelle relazioni.
Guardate un po' questa vignetta
che volevo condividere con voi,
che meraviglia che è!
(Vignetta)
Bambino 1: Che stupido regalo...
Bambino 2: Anche tu stai portando
un regalo al tuo papà?
Non è fantastica?
Secondo me è di una poesia eccezionale!
Dobbiamo partire da questo,
dalle nostre relazioni
che devono essere sinceri.
Ho scoperto da poco
che sincero deriva dal latino "sine cera"
con riferimento all'abitudine
degli scultori
di nascondere gli errori
nelle proprie opere con la cera.
Sincero è colui
che non ha nulla da nascondere.
E quindi questo ci permette
di avere la comunicazione
che sia fatta di scambio
e non una comunicazione
volta alla dominazione.
Perché è nella diversità,
nell'incontro con gli altri
che noi scopriamo anche noi stessi.
Spesso a scuola io dipingo
e scrivo con un gessetto sul muro bianco
e i ragazzi rimangono stupiti
proprio per farli riflettere
sul valore della diversità.
Noi siamo come il gessetto,
scopriamo noi stessi solo
attraverso gli altri.
Ognuno è un miracolo, ognuno è perfetto,
con i suoi limiti e talenti,
l'importante è che non cerchiamo
di imitare gli altri come in questo caso.
Il compito dell'educazione
dovrebbe essere quello
di aiutarci a scoprire i nostri talenti
Educare significa
letteralmente tirare fuori
c'è già tutto dentro,
i valori sono già tutti dentro,
noi non abbiamo bisogno
di mettere nulla dentro,
il valore della pace, della giustizia,
della libertà, sono già dentro
ad ognuno di noi,
si tratta di tirarli fuori
come in questo video meraviglioso
che ora vi vorrei mostrare.
Il tempo scaduto, come devo fare?
Ecco qua, guardatelo!
È l'esperimento con parte,
guardate che meraviglia.
Faccio notare l'età.
Questo siamo noi,
questo è l'animo umano.
La condivisione è innata.
Vedete non è neanche
chi è senza che chiede.
È l'altro offre spontaneamente.
Allora forse noi
dovremmo imparare dai bambini.
A parte questo furbetto.
(Risate)
Dovremmo imparare dai nostri bambini
a condividere.
Fermo, perché siamo oltre con i tempi.
Dovremmo imparare dai bambini
e la creatività per me
è la capacità di rievocare,
di risvegliare
il bambino che c'è dentro di noi.
Guardate quest'immagine, ecco vedete
la nonnetta che non riesce a resistere
alla tentazione della campana
del gioco della campana.
E questo può essere applicato
in mille modi
per cercare di invitarci
a una corretta gestione dei rifiuti
ad attraversare le strisce,
questa è la creatività,
come capacità di trasformare
i limiti in opportunità.
Guardate, un invito alla lettura,
una campagna ad Ankara
per il risparmio idrico
contro la discriminazione,
per l'ambiente,
qui vedete le finte buche adesive
per invitare a rallentare,
in Italia siamo oltre
siamo già al 3D, devo dire.
(Applausi)
Questa è commuovente, permettetemi...
Scusate che ho sforato già i tempo,
non applaudite fino alla fine.
Questa è una macchina
per la risonanza magnetica pediatrica
trasformata in un galeone dei pirati.
È commuovente!
Io credo che dobbiamo davvero
trasformare
i limiti, i problemi in occasione.
Qualcuno ha detto:
"Non avere paura delle difficoltà,
l'aquilone si alza solo
con il vento contrario,
mai con il vento a favore.
Io ho trovato questa immagine
che secondo me descrive
il concetto ancora meglio!
E allora, lo stupore e la meraviglia
sono la chiave per il cambiamento
perché noi non siamo nati per soffrire
siamo stati creati per essere felici
quando mi invitano a parlare
del risparmio energetico,
io mostro sempre questa immagine.
Questo è il vero risparmio energetico!
Guardate un bambino neonato
quando è nella culla che dorme:
sorride, sorride!
Questo siamo noi, questo siamo noi!
(Applausi)
E allora concludo perché
stanno per entrare con la motosega.
La scuola ci dovrebbe deliberare
dalle nostre catene
e permetterci di tirare fuori
la meraviglia che è in noi.
Non dimenticatelo!
Grazie mille. Arrivederci!
(Applausi)